private feiern die gelten hier zum
beispiel in berlin jetzt nur bis 10 in
vielen anderen orten auch das heißt eben
dass tante und onkel oft oben raus feind
die sind dann nicht mehr dabei wenn man
drei kinder hat dazu noch großvater groß
motor von beiden seiten und so weit ist
man sehr schnell bei 10 darf mir der
status überhaupt sagen wer an der
familien tafel sitzt dann weihnachten
also weihnachten ist ja wirklich ein
fest auch gerade der familie und deshalb
muss alles ermöglicht werden dass sich
da auch familie rede jetzt nicht von
großfamilien mit 500 mitgliedern von
clans sondern mit familie kann familie
sich natürlich treffen kann
ich finde es richtig wie das in
nordrhein westfalen ist dass die
empfehlungen gegeben werden aber nicht
regelungen vorgegeben werden
verbindliche art weil sonst wirklich es
sein kann dass weihnachten an der tür
geklingelt wird dann steht da nicht der
weihnachtsmann sondern der polizist oder
informiert